now let's say you've got an ajna built
and you're you're very good at
controlling yourself
and controlling other people and you
know the physicals there the emotional's
there the mental is there
everything's great well
if a person who has a developed ajna
falls
into the lower centers it is bloody
dangerous
because they know how to control other
people
so then you get your hitlers and your
idi amines
and your murderous military dictators of
all ilk
you get the manipulators
the behind the scenes oh house of cards
okay the british version okay the
american one's okay
but watch the british version brilliant
and ian richardson is a plays a
character who has a developed ajna
center and drops
into the lower solar plexus about
personal power
and political machinations so
for the dark side if you want a really
really good
villain start them out or let us know
that they have developed that that
higher
ability to keep everything in balance
and to manipulate and have a sense of
integrity
and you can pull the strings they're
very very good at that
what would be the reason in a story that
you would have someone who
seems that balanced fall
well again we could go back to the lure
of the dark side
but mostly what you'll see when you have
a character fall from
the ajna down into the darkness is
there has been some disappointment or
setback
they've had some kind of heartbreak
something didn't go well
see more at darth vader okay we see his
background and
we begin to see oh yeah you can kind of
understand how that worked
so give your character some big loss
and maybe they when they're a child
maybe
they lose their dog okay but then they
go on to
develop their ozna but then they have
another big loss
and that one breaks them they've already
got a weak spot
and then the loss of another close
friend or
pet just sends them down
and it's also a loss of faith
so whether or not they are religious or
spiritual
it's a dark night of the soul from which
they do not rise
so you shatter something in their lives
and they just go what the heck why
bother
i'm just going to get mine
you